in iraq's town of barthela the christian
orthodox march mooney church has
reopened its doors
it was partly destroyed by isil as the
group launched its offensive through
northern iraq in 2014
but there are few worshipers to fill its
restored nave
dawud suleiman has been a pastor here
for 24 years
and has gradually watched his
congregation shrink
if this hard situation continues it will
be difficult for christians to stay in
iraq
maybe we will persist but the next
generation no
we cannot force them to stay
partella used to be a christian majority
town but over the past four decades
the number of muslims here has steadily
grown
in the 1980s then president saddam
hussein nationalized farmland belonging
to christians
and gave it to families of soldiers
killed in the iran-iraq war
in 2014 isil took over forcing the
christian population to flee
almost half emigrated abroad about a
quarter have returned
while another quarter remain in the
semi-autonomous kurdish region
members of this family in arabia's
christian quarter of ankawa
say the reason they don't feel safe to
go back is the security force that
controls the
town they want to remain anonymous for
security reasons of course safety is the
most important thing we've had enough of
the infringements on our lands
the area should be controlled by the
sons of the area why do they bring
strangers to rule the area
that group is the 30th brigade of the
shia led popular
mobilization forces which helped retake
bartella from isil
the brigade is composed of ethnic chabak
just like most of the muslim population
that lives here
last year its leader wat kado was placed
under u.s
sanctions for alleged human rights
abuses against christians
kado was forced to step down two months
ago he denies the charges against him
i believe there's no control of one
faction over another
we the shabbat and the christians have
been residents of the area for a long
time
the christians are welcome to return
back to live in their homes and we
support these returns
there's complete stability and security
the majority of the town is now shabbat
many shopkeepers in this market are
shabbat who have bought or rented shops
that used to be run by christians
one of them muhammad adnan who recently
returned
believe such changes are a natural
development
it's the purchasing power that is ruling
the situation the christians don't have
money to buy
but the muslims can buy but many
christians say they are being pushed out
and that much of the construction in
bartela is funded by people in power who
want to accelerate the demographic
change
the vatican's announcement of pope
francis visit to iraq has given many
christians hope
that what is left of their heritage can
be preserved
but the demographic changes here are so
extensive
that few believe they can be reversed
simona faulting al jazeera